the border is secure the Border we are
working to make the Border more secure
that has been a historic challenge
secretary mayor orcas do you continue to
maintain that the border is secure
yes and we are working day in and day
out to enhance its security Congressman
I
mean Sheriff what kind of reception did
my orcas expect in light of the fact
this is that this Administration has
turned their back on the border agents
and oh by the way lie to them
yeah he's completely tone deaf like the
rest of this Administration and it's
crazy how they're doing it about face
right now as if the Americans are going
to forget what they said before look at
what Gavin newsom's doing in California
I'm starting to see the Mainstream
media's other outlets unlike Fox that's
been reporting it all the way along now
you got like CNN starting to report it
so they're doing this about Facebook
because what they're going to do is for
the next two years they're going to talk
about it and claim you know pretend like
they didn't say it wasn't a crisis for
the last two years he deserved the cold
welcome and that's exactly what he got
because he's turned his back on them and
they see him as a complete coward
Sheriff a week away from the end of
title 42 and the Biden Administration
just filed a lawsuit against Arizona to
stop your state from putting up shipping
containers to build a makeshift border
wall to try and contain this crisis how
do you feel about that timing
yeah we don't like the timing but you
know what this is par for the course you
know 10 years ago or 12 years ago we did
SB 1070 here in Arizona which would have
made it illegal in the state to be in
the state illegally and we could have
charged them on a State Crime of course
the federal government was there to try
to stop us for that that was under the
Obama Administration we have seen this
time and time again that every time
Arizona or Texas or any other state
tries to do something to protect their
own borders and their communities the
federal government will swoop in with
taxpayed lawyers by the way begrudgingly
taxpayed lawyers and they're going to
try to stop anything effective that we
do here in our state here's what the
lawsuit claims quote damages Federal
lands threatens Public Safety and
impedes the ability of federal agencies
and officials including law enforcement
Personnel to perform their official
doozy duties lawyers speaking here you
know what's happening they want to stop
it and they're trying to figure out the
best legal way they think to stop it
that explanation is pure BS let's call
it what it is the bite Administration
logically from its efforts here wants
the border to be open and there really
is no other conclusion is their Sheriff
no there isn't they've always wanted to
undermine the rule of law and what
better way to do it than to open the
borders and allow these communities to
be flooded with who knows who you know
Yuma County's getting 70 Russians a day
they had one group of 400 Russians which
by the way there was ukrainians and
Russians in that group miraculously they
weren't fighting but 70 Russians a day
along with many people from other
countries showing up they're getting
over a thousand a day in Yuma alone El
Paso's being overrun I just talked to
another guy who's down there who said
there's some large very large groups one
after another passing through New Mexico
just outside of El Paso this is crazy
and it's not going to get any better if
this Administration doesn't do something
about it but we're not going to fall for
this whole hey we wanted it secure this
whole time
um but that's just a flat out lie and my
orcas is just a liar yeah you know it's
sort of a simple question here but I'm
why does everything rely on title 42
when it is still illegal all to cross
into this country illegally shouldn't
there be something else that can be
easily implemented that could replace it
to get this situation under control
Carly you are a common sense person I've
been asking that for a long time it's
illegal why do we need title 42 to use
it to send them back you know I'm glad
we have title 42 because that's the all
the border patrol has left but I want
the American people to know when you see
these apprehensions like for example in
Yuma 95 of these people at least are
being let into the country and like your
glass guest said they let everybody else
in but the one guy that they didn't let
in was the guy that they should have let
in that's how ridiculous this is and we
live it every single day here in Arizona
and Texas
um and it's it's pretty frustrating I
think Carly raises such a great point
there is something in place it's called
the law and they're breaking it on a
day-to-day basis Sheriff Mark Lamb thank
you very much thank you so much